ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
bullpen
[Music]
my dear brother and friend David packman
of the David packman show is on this
show National broadcaster and
extraordinary individual
David thanks for being on the show how
are you my pleasure I'm so glad to be
here all right we're going to chop it up
about a couple of items but let me start
with what we have seen lately
this anti-jewish rhetoric
spewed by Kanye West
eaten up by individuals since including
white supremacists who are completely
antithetical to the progress of anybody
but white people and white supremacy
I don't want to presume what you feel
about these elements so I wanted to
bring you on the show
allow you to express your sentiment and
let's talk about it openly what are your
thoughts yeah I mean listen it's it's
not surprising that such a prominent
public figure repeating just about every
common and typical anti-semitic Trope
and stereotype is being met with a
stunning amount of support if you look
at the YouTube comments on my channel
when I've talked about the things that
Kanye West has said there's a shocking
number of people who go listen David
he's just right you know he's just
speaking the truth uh and he's finally
saying the things that the very Jewish
media he criticizes don't allow to be
said which is just sort of a it's a
repetition it's a recycling of the very
tropes themselves so similar to you know
I don't really think Donald Trump
created more racism or xenophobia I
think he used the language that made
people that believed a lot of this stuff
more comfortable admitting it publicly I
think it's a similar thing with Kanye
but I do think to some degree there are
folks who were just Kanye fans they
didn't think much about Jews one way or
the other who are only hearing this and
saying I don't know maybe he is making
some good points so so he actually may
be convincing some people with some of
this stuff David you bring up a good
point and every time I've done a story
where I've highlighted the Coalition
between uh Jews and civil rights leaders
where I've talked about the insanity of
Kanye West and his comments and
commentary and how really people that
say they're awoke are identifying with
white supremacy now because Kanye said
it every time I bring that up go to the
comment section I get the same thing I
get people saying that I'm not black
anymore or somehow I'm contrary to
progress of the black community and I
find it really interesting because it
was Kanye West
who said that slavery was a choice
it was Kanye West who said George Floyd
killed himself
it was Kanye West who wore White lives
matter shirt
and stood next to the number one black
white supremacist Candice Owens who
refuses to wear a black lives matter
shirt it was him that did these things
in in contradiction to his own Blackness
and in contradiction to the community
that first validated him let's be very
clear
White America would not know who Kanye
West was without Black America
validating him first we did that for him
and he has lived a life contrary now
currently
um opposite of that sentiment and that
uh approval that we gave them so you
hear this
you see what's happening
you see people are more emboldened all
right standing on Bridges Etc
where do you think this goes
I I don't know where it goes and the
reason I say that is there is a soft
anti-Semitism that exists that's kind of
the term I use where there are folks who
will say yeah I've heard the stereotypes
but at the end of the day Jews are a
privileged population in America and so
we don't really need to worry about it
plus a lot of these stereotypes are kind
of positive you know they sound like
kind of pretty good things so there is
unfortunately I mean listen the hard
right white supremacists we know their
View
but
we have this other layer which is this
softer anti-Semitism that I find
problematic as well because a lot of
folks don't know necessarily well a lot
of those stereotypes that sound kind of
okay I'd love people to say hey uh we're
good at business that sounds good but
what they don't understand are the
discriminatory historical realities that
led to that stereotype the fact that it
sounds positive but what they're really
saying is there is a concerted
conspiratorial effort
among Jews to control an industry
there's a lot of other stuff wrapped up
in it and a lot of people just don't
understand that in their defense
everybody's busy living their lives
right it's not they're not necessarily
bad people because they don't know this
stuff but it can the soft anti-Semitism
can be very recalcitrant
you know it was Dr King who said we
should judge people based on the content
of their character uh there are
individuals I am allied with because of
their individual values
um I understand that there are
individuals inside of that group that
may be completely contrary to my values
that goes for every demographic
including the Jewish demographic there
are those who are absolutely forming
they're those who may not be but we even
find that in uh the movement for black
lives uh we found that during the time
of Dr King uh my college students were
shocked when I told them less than 10 of
churches would even allow Dr King to
speak at their churches only six percent
of America was actually in support of Dr
King based on a survey done by NBC when
he was living so the curated Dr King we
have today the more digestible Dr King
will have today was not a digestible
individual back then according to the
sentiment of the majority of Americans
and even the majority of preachers who
would not allow him black preachers in
particular who would not allow him just
output in their church but that doesn't
mean
that I'm now anti-black people or
anti-black church or anti this anti-bat
I'm still
connecting with people based on values
and based on the content of their
character how do you think we lost this
David at some point you know I I don't
know and again like you say every
demographic group in the United States
has examples of everything and one of
the things that I am sort of very
disappointed by and upset by is what was
historically a really important alliance
between Jewish folks and black folks in
the United States that has to a little
bit of a degree been ruptured because of
some uh anti-Semitism within the black
community and I told the story on my
show if you know the famous Mississippi
Burning story where three people were
killed two of the three people were
Jewish folks from New York City who
understood the goals here are so similar
between our groups of people the
historical circumstances have
similarities although they are not by
any means the same there are important
value similarities where we should be
Allied here rather than butting heads
and it's it's disappointing to see that
in certain enclaves that has completely
broken down
you know uh I finished doctoral studies
at Clark Atlanta University Clark
Atlanta University has a connection to
W.E.B Du Bois and we've always
considered him to be one of our strong
black Scholars obviously he was a black
intellectual but he also understood the
necessity of black progress in America
and so he created coalitions with Jewish
Americans and those coalitions were very
strong including the NAACP which was a
Jewish black Coalition initially in the
foundation of it but he also received
criticism from people like Marcus Garvey
uh he received criticism from others who
were for progress but did not like his
ideology but I do find it quite
interesting that today we can actually
study both ideologies both of these men
as individuals as well as Leaders of a
particular movement and appreciate what
they brought to the table while
understanding we may not agree with
every element they subscribe to the new
wants that Nuance doesn't exist in this
era as it did back then or in the
context of History do you agree I
completely agree and the the other part
of this that I think is important and
this is particularly relevant in the era
of Maga and this is not exactly what
you're talking about but it's another
layer
there's a reflexive Instinct by some to
say this isn't this whole Kanye thing
it's not about anti-Semitism it's about
mental illness he says he's not taking
the pills that a Jewish doctor told him
to take this is mental illness plain and
simple and it's really important not to
see these things as either or or one or
the other there's lots of mental illness
and mentally ill individuals who have
good or bad ideas who have inclusive or
discriminatory ideas and also there is
anti-Semitism and other types of racism
and xenophobia that has nothing to do
with mental illness or it might overlap
with it and one of the other concerns
when you talk about seeing in seeing
people as individuals and evaluating the
things they say you don't have to ignore
the content of what they say because
there may be a mental illness component
and that's another thing that is
unfortunately being used by some to sort
of not necessarily excuse but diminish
the importance of the content of what
Kanye has been saying you know we have
to take things based on its impact
that's literally how we respond as a
societal construct this has great impact
freedom of speech Let's talk about that
before we have to end this interview uh
freedom of speech
is not freedom of consequence or freedom
from consequence
uh somehow somehow
either Kanye or the people who support
Kanye and it is bigger than Kanye I'm
just using him as a utilizing this as a
microcosm
why would Kanye escape the cause and
effect relationship of freedom of speech
Yes but it does not mean freedom from
consequence we all have that Dynamic
connected to us anything we offer for
the public will either be criticized or
it will be supported that's how this
works what are your thoughts about this
sentiment now a lot of it is pushed from
the conservatives that suggest and some
flat out say freedom of speech should
mean freedom from consequence yeah I
mean that's not new that's that's an old
Trope which is they most loudly talk
about freedom of speech but they want
there to be no consequences to them
using that freedom of speech with that
which they claim someone else I guess
the left or Democrats are trying to take
away from them they're absolutely
consequences to speech assuming that
they are not a violation of one's First
Amendment rights valid should be
expected part of the discourse and the
dialogue that exists one of the really
unfortunate things that's happening with
the Kanye situation is the fact that his
outrageous speech is having consequences
is being used to say look he's right he
said this stuff and now the very Jewish
media he attacked is silencing him and
one and that's that can be very
difficult to escape the bubble of and
it's very damaging that that's taking
place
earlier today I saw this on uh social
media took cross and flat out saying
that hate speech does not actually exist
now remember he's an ally now of Kanye
West uh Kanye West I think it's more
strategic than most people give him
credit for because he goes out of his
out of his way David to not offend
racist white people what are your
thoughts on that
uh 100 and the it I I don't know whether
these are ideas that we've heard over
the last three weeks from Kanye that he
stumbled upon himself or whether people
have been suggesting or giving him some
of this material but the material is
aligning absolutely perfectly with what
a lot of those racist folks already
believe and much like with Trump they
heard a little kernel of something that
sounded pretty good they're hearing it
from Kanye right now
David always a pleasure dear brother
talking to you I appreciate what you
continue to do in your advocacy and your
platforms for those who may be living
under a rock and they don't know how to
check out your shows please tell them
how they can do so yeah just my
website's the the central place
davidpackman.com thank you my friend
until next time thank you